Taylor Swift has yet again broken up  with another boyfriend  this time it's with One Direction singer  Harry Styles yeah and as is her custom  Taylor has already written a song about  this particularly painful breakup we  managed to get an advance copy of the  song yeah yeah check it out day of the  week enduring three-syllable personal  traits synonym for sadness that rhymes  with age please choose from the  following Harry Connor  you believe John Gotti quite like oh not  patented the other guy Lucas and one of  the Jonas Brothers I want to say Dwight  [Music]  [Music]  who could forget Dwight Jonah oh he's my  favorite he's the cutest